titanfall 2's multiplayer is a chaotic
and frenetic affair which often makes it
difficult for beginners to keep up with
that's why we've compiled 11 tips to
help you build up your skills so you can
be well on your way to becoming a master
Titan pilot number one play single
player first titanfall two single-player
campaign is a great place to learn the
basics needed to take on multiplayer
from wall running to the various
strengths and weaknesses of each Titan
type the five-hour campaign offers
plenty of scenarios for you to test the
game systems physics and mechanics
number two learn and understand the wall
run titanfall 2 is all about movement
the faster you are the harder you are to
kill but if you want to go fast you'll
need to master the wall run as it
drastically increases your movement
speed the game's maps are packed with
vertical surfaces so be sure to run
across them to build up momentum combine
it with your double jump to cross gaps
to keep your wall run chain going the
extra jump can also be a handy way to
throw off enemy fire but be aware that
doing so slows you down when chained
methodically wall running can make you
an untouchable foe but if used
senselessly you'll be an easy target
number three picking a Titan each of the
game's six Titans have their own
distinct play styles on loadouts
ion is a well rounded Titan recommended
for beginners and great at mid-range
combat scorch is a Titan focus on area
of effect damage it's at its strongest
when pulling in multiple enemy Titans
with its ignitable gas traps North Star
is a sniper Titan that's best use behind
frontlines it packs a lot of firepower
but is weak in close range combat Ronin
is a hit and run Titan with powerful
melee attacks and great maneuverability
tonne is a Titan that can lock on in
fire missiles at enemy Titans and if you
smartly these missiles can curve around
corners and hit foes hiding in cover
Legion is a Titan that's good at all
ranges but needs time to charge up its
minigun which can be destructive
powerhouse when allowed to fully unload
number 4 spend your credits wisely
double check when an item you want
unlocks since you might be getting it
sooner than you think through level
progression it's better to spend your
hard-earned credits on items boosts and
perks that are unlockable further down
the road number 5 be a team player with
batteries when you're lucky enough to
snag a battery from the enemy
into a friendly tighten this boosts not
only its shields but also greatly
increases your titanfall meter however
if your ticker is at 90% save it for
your own title smart battery use can
turn the tide of battle but be careful
batteries glow when stepped onto your
back which makes you an easy target
number 6 how to fight Titans as a pilot
Titans can be intimidating foes to run
into but if you're smart you can take
one down with ease first throw an arc
grenade or use a fire starter blinded
this allows you to get close then engage
your grapple and use it as a fulcrum to
zip over a Titan and onto its back so
you can pry away its battery or throw
grenades down it but make sure to avoid
grappling the front of an enemy Titan
though if this tactic isn't for you
try using cloak to sneak up on the Titan
to pull their battery that way but be
mindful they can see the sparks of your
jump Jets a Titan isn't defenseless
though if it deploys its electric smoke
attack jump off immediately and stock it
until the smoke clears number 7 don't
rely on anti-titan weapon anti-titan
weapons might seem useful to bring into
battle but most of the time they're not
that effective it's better to focus your
attention on taking out pilots or AI
enemies if you're playing bounty hunt or
attrition so equip that weapon slot with
something that'll help you pick them off
however if you do bring an anti Titan
weapon into battle we recommend the
magnetic grenade launcher it's a handy
weapon useful for both Titan and pilot
combat number eight know when to move
and when to stay still by design
titanfall 2 demands that you keep moving
to survive enemy gunfire but sometimes
it helps to slow things down to mess
with your enemy's expectations try
cloaking yourself and waiting for
enemies to pass by to surprise attack
you can also hunker down and use the a
wall ability a pilot sized particle
shield that enhances outgoing shots
making it essential for sniping
defending the flag or holding down hard
points number 9 mow down AI enemies if
pilots are giving you a hard time and
bounty hunter attrition try bumping up
your team's score by ticking out AI
enemies see a group of grunts toss a
frag or fire started them and keep
moving don't go out of your way for AI
but do your best to kill them whenever
convenient single digits can often
determine matches in bounty hunter
attrition so it helps to kill AI to help
your
team in the long run as well as speed up
your titanfall number 10 understand
boosts titanfall 2 contains items called
boosts which are equippable enhancements
you can use once your titanfall meter
reaches a certain percentage for
instance the map pack boost reveals
enemies to your entire team once your
titanfall reaches 70% there are plenty
of boosts choose from so it's important
to figure out which one works for you
but choose wisely
you can only equip one boost at a time
and they cannot be switched mid match
number 11 check your inbox often for
goodies as you level up a character
known as The Advocate will send messages
to your titanfall to inbox these
messages contain special goodies like
call signs and blooms and camos for both
your Titan and pilot and those are 11
beginners tips to get you started in
titanfall two's multiplayer practice put
them to good use and good luck in the
field
you